but it does and they're like no no stuff
comes out there's just no sperm in there
that's their number one concern that
they'll never come against like no
you're still gonna come so I tell him
that he goes good to know I didn't know
that yeah like a ego thing because it's
like I I don't want to be shooting
blanks yeah I want to be a fertile man
that's right that's right I've ever
heard a man say did you hear about Phil
shoots blanks now yeah and I was the
first one to say I love you and we were
laying in bed and it was right before we
were talking about to go to sleep it's
like on a five months in or something
okay and I was like I love you and he
was like
what the [ __ ] did you just say to me and
he goes wait I know it's way worse he
goes I said Thank you and I go oh I
[ __ ] heard you dude I was giving you
a chance to dial it back like what do
you mean and he goes well I mean like I
think that's great like he's like I
don't like I'm not there yet I could see
myself getting there but would you
rather like I lie and say I love you too
I said [ __ ] yes I would yeah what yeah
you lie pause and think of something
else besides thank you I don't know
thank you is this a [ __ ] business
trainer what do you mean
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to Big mood today is a very
special day because we have a very
special guest with us this is Jay hi hi
jokes by Jay so I'm so excited to have
her here by the way so I brought her
she's she's a friend of mine so anyway
we'll get to know her in a second but
who else is here hi it's me Gina yeah we
do have friends outside of our group
isn't that amazing
[ __ ] yeah it's me Jess I'm here oh you
did it it's me too yes
so anyway Jay let's get to know you so
would you like to
um share with the room how we met I
would love to so I never made it as a
stand-up comedy person I stand up
comedian I never I never did well with
it which is very sad so I have a
full-time job and
yeah that's true I chose having a family
over being homeless in a van driving
from City to city until I had an HBO
special so here we are
I I still actually think about leaving
them just for a weekend we'll talk about
that later so I have a full-time job I
work at a dental office a cosmetic
dental office and uh actually Tiff comes
in with her husband and they are
influencers actually yeah for our office
they help us promote our office which is
funny yeah and she had no idea that I
even did comedy because it's a very
separate thing I don't talk about it
when I'm when I'm there and so she came
in and recently because we were both
pregnant at the same time yeah oh we
were both pregnant and I'm sure as you
guys know she didn't know she was having
a boy or girl I knew I was having a boy
and we talked at length for hours yeah
every time I go to my appointments and
Casey too like we literally we're done
with our appointment and we stayed for
like another hour just talking about
just chatting about the pregnancy
nothing about a comedy nothing like that
just talking about and um yeah and then
so I went on maternity leave and it was
funny I had meant to like me and Casey
were like let's stay in touch and I want
to know if it's a boy or girl and of
course then and I had a nine pound four
ounce baby at home Jesus at home that
was amazing oh so I was a little
distracted
and I forgot to
fraternity leave she came in and we were
chatting and I find out it's a boy I
found out the whole birth story which
was incredible and I'm like what's his
name and she's like Luca and I'm like
she's like you're kidding what do you
mean
yes no she's like no it was a joke right
that's fine the thing is like how did
you know my son's name to come up with
this joke and I and I feel like she's
not going to believe me I would show her
like something you know what I mean
so yeah this is the most crazy is that
Casey and I had a whole conversation
about names and they didn't know about
boys names and all he said was we have a
ton of girls names that was the length
of the conversation like we have all
these girls names picked out but we
don't know what we were gonna do if it's
a boy right and I knew I was gonna name
my baby Luca for a long time but I never
said anything about it you know it was
bananas yeah like oh my God craziest
coincidence and how old is Luca so he's
oh next week he'll be eight months okay
so and mine is my Luca six and a half
months so they're very close in age two
right they're six weeks apart or
something like that yeah yeah no well
Luca was supposed to be seven months
next week or right like he's a month
older than he should be and and mine
came out five days late yeah with pretty
much a backpack on ready a briefcase
so
um so yeah it was just crazy and then we
got chatting and then she you know we're
talking about being moms she's like oh
I'll follow you on Instagram and I gave
her my personal Instagram page and then
Barrett who works in my office who
coordinates all these you know these
guys coming in these you famous
influencers coming in um I was like oh
give her your comedy page she's like
what comment like what are you talking
about and I gave it to her and I was
like yeah it's jokes by Jay and she
she's like oh my God and you know why
don't you come be a guest yeah my pocket
is like shut up I would love that
like an opportunity to just talk for
hours yes please do it we will sit here
and shut up yeah no she's been three
years fun like she's so fun to talk to
like I'm telling you we literally spend
like hours after our appointment and
then like our car is in the valet
everyone's like are you gonna come pick
up your car like no it's just I'm gonna
they're like wait can we get an extra
cleaning this year we just kind of want
to yeah
on my last appointment I went home and I
realized oh [ __ ] I didn't make my next
appointment because I was just talking
to her that's awesome yeah I don't know
I checked out of the hole like this is
my job
and I was like how good of a Time Janine
is there's only people who thinks your
teeth is [ __ ] up like every time this
[ __ ] comes in she's sitting there why
is she here every three weeks
for two hours
yeah yeah so and then so how I started
my thing is like years ago I always had
this I've always had this passion to
like create laughter in the masses you
know like I feel like no matter what you
have going on in life you know if you
you lost someone if you're whatever's
going on for you you when you are like
belly laughing like so hard that your
eyes are tearing you can't [ __ ]
breathe like that kind of laugh you're
just like checked out of all that you
know what I mean you're so disconnected
from it that I always wanted to do stand
up because I'm like if I could create
that in a large group of people oh my
God that's [ __ ] awesome you know so
my best friend actually was like um I
signed this up for a stand-up comedy
class and I was like you're the worst
person on the planet well when was that
uh that was
let's see
2013.
so uh and I was going to be getting
married in the summer of that year
I'm also like you know traditionally
like you get married and the bride's
parents are supposed to like pay for
everything that's not my situation yeah
so we were like credit cards
[ __ ] flower balls in my living room
and so that was what we were doing and I
was like I don't I don't want to do this
and she she's like well we're going and
I'm like I I literally will I'm not
talking you're not you're a horrible
friend I don't know why I did that she
paid for it so I'm like I'm gonna
[ __ ] go with her yeah because she
paid for her right I'm like God damn it
so I go and at the end of the first
class I look over her and I was like
you're the best friend
I love you so much for this this is
amazing she knew yeah and I was just
scared you know I was scared right so
like you're scared that you're not going
to create the effect you want to create
you know what I mean like you're like
what if I what if it's not funny what if
I think I'm funny you know but any
moment like any memory I have that's
like near and dear to me or like moments
where I'm in a group of people and I'm
making them laugh I'm telling a story or
whatever so we do this class and at the
end of the class you're supposed to go
perform like at an actual comedy club
and you have a five minute set that
you've created throughout the class
right so I'm like okay so we do it I get
up on stage I'm just like I don't even
remember it do you know what I mean like
an out of Body Experience because you're
like adrenaline yeah and then I get off
the stage and I was like I want to do
that again like it was just like my
addicting yes and I already have a dream
people were laughing like do you
remember seeing the reactions at least
no what I did was but it's okay because
um I had voice recorded like the on the
iPhone you know like a voice record and
so I was able to listen later for like
what jokes yeah and what did well and
then I worked that out and so I was like
okay I'm fine good I did good you know
and then I started doing that I was at
the comedy store and I was at the Improv
and I was like at all these different
places and it was so fun and most of my
set was revolving around how I was about
to get married you know and then I got
married and so I changed that joke a
little bit and then my husband wanted to
have kids and I was like oh my God I
just lost all this weight I looked great
you know
um and then he wanted to have kids and I
was like oh God damn we're fine okay
yeah we're fine so then I you know I got
pregnant and I was like I'm not gonna do
stand up like who wants to hear I was
like a house and then in hindsight it
would have been so funny and I [ __ ]
that up yeah totally so I I mean like
Ellie Wong to a whole yeah especially
pregnant yes yeah I saw it yeah and I
was like God damn it so anyway I I have
my daughter and then now I'm like okay
so I'm a mother of two because my I have
a I have a six-year-old and I have a six
month old and I'm like there's so much
material yeah in all of it in like
having home birth like having two kids
like all of that stuff and it's like you
know I need to rewrite my set because my
whole that was about getting married and
having kids and all this right so I've
started to like get back into that but
during covid my same best friend who
signed me up for my
um class you know I she was like
you know you should do your stand-up
bits on Tick Tock yeah what the [ __ ] is
Tick Tock yeah yeah I'm also probably
the oldest person in this room how old
are you let's see I just turned 39. okay
I'm 35 so yeah look at you 35.
I can tell your skin is still nice and
tight that's really good it's Botox
honey I I have to return on
breastfeeding I plan on just my whole I
want my face Frozen in time yeah it was
just me laughing yeah yeah right and
this is me crying yeah you know what I
mean that's what I was kind of going so
yeah emotionless just Frozen in time so
I was like okay sorry figure out Tick
Tock I'm like what is this so I start
doing that right and within like you
know a very short period of time I don't
know I got like 60 000 followers I was
so excited about that right and I'm like
congratulations thank you and then I did
this dumb [ __ ] thing at my office so
I have a co-worker who speaks Spanish
right Katya you know Katya yeah and so
somebody calls and they're like
I'm like hang on a sec una momento por
favor and I'm like yeah this one's for
you so she picks up the phone and they
have the wrong office and however you
say that you probably know right yeah uh
how do you say you have the wrong number
yeah okay so she said something that
sounded like avocado and so so I was
like I said that and they all laughed
and Barrett goes you should you should
do a tick tock about that all right [ __ ]
it so we do we reenact what happened
and we do a tick tock in the next day it
has like over a million views I'm like
oh [ __ ] and there's all these people
like can you say this and blah blah can
you say this in Arabic and German and
yeah so I start doing that and those 60
000 followers are now at like almost
500k all just from the language yeah
I'm like she's like I just don't like
the attention I was like she's like you
know what I mean I'm like not at all but
okay like
apparently I don't understand that I
love attention but I I okay like so I
started using Google translate yeah and
then I can do any language anywhere yeah
which is nice and it's taken off to this
thing that I was like this is the
dumbest joke I've ever seen and it's you
know what I never know what's gonna
happen you have no idea you know and so
you should definitely check out your
Tick Tock so it's jokes by Jay it's so
funny like she just goes through all
these kinds of languages I feel like
Casey should kind of like insert a
couple little Clips yeah or something
yeah
yeah please can I explain this we can
all watch it right now because I want I
need I need any she needs to see it to
see okay we'll keep talking you look it
up yeah and then I did like I love
talking obviously I mean I don't think
anyone else does this is okay
that's why you're here yeah
you can just keep keep running okay
great yeah
okay first of all you look stunning oh
thank you that was because I was lighter
um there's a really great filter on Tick
Tock by the way I'll talk about it later
so so yeah so then I did twitch for a
while because I have this just chatting
thing and I could just sit there and
just talk just like one way flow of
communication I don't have to like yeah
it was wonderful people were typed up
and I was like okay yeah we'll get to
that but it was just like wonderful for
me because I started off doing Tick Tock
lives nice and those words I didn't know
they even had that yeah I'm not on tick
tocks I don't know much about it stand
on there for [ __ ] no reason at all it
was temporary yeah they're like wait
like of all ticks somebody told me what
I was doing was like Ray sisters and I
was like hang on a second no no no no
first of all knock it off okay secondly
no don't like don't even go there with
me with this kind of [ __ ] because I'm
literally like people are asking me to
do this and I'm trying to make people
laugh yeah and I'm intentionally they're
like are you even gonna try and the
whole schtick is that I intend
functionally [ __ ] it up but I have so
much confidence that I nailed it yeah
that that's what makes it funny you know
what I mean and they're like because
people are like oh it's the confidence
like for me like she's like I got this
and I totally Slaughter it you know not
everyone understands humor no there's a
difference it's humor I get it like I
don't have to but you don't just you
don't have to report they report me for
being right and I was like damn oh my
gosh this is crazy and teaching a white
person Spanish is that the one you want
okay what do I say to a Spanish speaker
when they call the office and they have
the wrong number how do I say it
again
I will see where the avocado came from
right
hello
oh they're Spanish oh my God
el numero El avocado
okay adios
but then like so then there's apparently
there's this whole um because I have one
that one of them is like I like hit
almost six million views oh my God this
and it's pinned on my on my tech talk
like on the page you'll see it I have
like a leopard something on you got it
there you go I want this is so stupid
and a whole bunch of
I can't oh no that's French that's the
French one 5.6 4.6 uh let me see yes no
which which language
or give her the phone letter oh it might
not be pinned sorry guys please hold why
would you come into my house we're gonna
pause for a commercial break I totally
lied to you it's not it's not my house
it's early in the morning you know what
Jay it was nice having you it's that
middle one right there okay
I love Korean how do I say you're crazy
how was your day in Korea
exactly exactly again
who doesn't like this song
this is what I that's what they said I
don't know
I love this song
I can how do I say I hate bullies in
French
and lasagna and my detour yes
so
um yeah so that's going well that's
awesome because you found the thing
about Tick Tock it's you have to find a
niche 100 and you have to keep doing it
Evergreen Niche yeah and just keep doing
that and it works and that's [ __ ]
awesome yeah thank you yeah and it's fun
and it's again something I can do in a
short period of time because there were
like these lip syncing ones and stuff
that I would do that are a 30 second
video would take me an hour and I'm like
I don't I don't have the time for this
like I'm neglecting yeah
like how hard do I want to create this
laugh it's ridiculous yeah so it's like
a little bit desperate at this point so
I had to I had to kind of reel it in and
be like this is something I can do in a
very short period of time and still work
and I have like two jobs so I work at
the dental office and I'm like a
bookkeeper for another cup for my
husband's production company and like
there's a it's a lot and then I have
these two kids you know what I mean yeah
that you know just all the things you
said I don't know if you have this
problem but like all the things that you
say you never do like before I had kids
I'm like I will never leave my kids with
a nanny yeah cocaine while breastfeeding
I've seen that happen I would never do
yeah I don't breastfeed no I'm kidding
I'm joking so um so so no but I like oh
there's all these things she's like I'm
like I would never leave my kid with a
nanny I'm gonna stay at home you know
I'm never gonna give them a phone
watch TV no sugar my daughter is
watching TV right now at six
all right ladies Christmas is just
around the corner and you know your man
needs a skincare routine because
everyone needs a skincare routine and
also gentlemen if you're listening you
know I'm talking to YouTube and that's
where geology comes in geology is a
nine-time award-winning men's skin care
company recognized in men's health
Esquire and ask men grooming Awards
there are over 5 000 five-star reviews
geology creates a simple and effective
skincare routine customized just for you
with ingredients that are proven to work
and formulated for daily use the product
set is great for both individuals new to
skincare and seasoned Skin Care Experts
geology skincare is built around just a
handful of powerful proven ingredients
that have been trusted by German
intelligence for decades geology is one
of the only men's skin care companies to
have retinol as an active ingredient in
their products geology skin care helps
you fight acne reduce oiliness prevent
wrinkles and combat dark and puffy under
eyes which by the way 50 of guys suffer
from under eye issues like dark under
eye circles puffiness tired eyes fine
lines and wrinkles take for example my
own wonderful husband Casey now that
he's been getting older he has been
noticing some wrinkles around his eyes
some crow's feet so when I heard that
geology was sponsoring our podcast I was
so excited to have him try their
award-winning eye cream so we haven't
received it just yet but Casey's
definitely looking forward to it and so
am I because I've heard so many good
things about geology so I'm really
excited for him to try it out and see a
difference in his own skin which I'm
very confident he will be so it's pretty
cool because geology has a 30-day trial
of all four products works because
obviously Their Skin Care works best as
a set so what you get with the 30-day
trial is two everyday face wash one for
your sink and one for your shower or to
take with you to the gym you also get
vital morning face cream repairing night
cream and that nourishing eye cream that
I'm talking about geology also has
exceptional customer service and skin
consultation they guarantee that you
will love geology and help you at every
step of the way to achieve your goals
people will notice the results and
you'll love the easy routine and you
will definitely look younger and feel
fresh every single day so what you do is
you click the link in the description or
you go to geology.com big mood and you
take a 30 seconds diagnostic quiz and
with a few clicks you tell them about
your skin and goals and their team of
dermatologists will design a regimen
just for you that is shipped directly to
your door it's that simple so head to
geology.com Big mood and take their free
skincare quiz to save up to 70 off on
your 30 days trial even better join
their new geology Galaxy Community for
more daily tips giveaways and more at
discord.gg geology that's spelled
g-e-o-l-o-g-i-e thanks to geology for
sponsoring today's video so here we are
that's amazing how does your husband
feel about the tick tock Fame
you know my husband and I are very
different people like I like everything
done yesterday and he like I'll ask him
to do something like babe can you hang
that picture and he's like what do you
mean like I'm sorry I'm okay can you
relax the picture on the wall and he
goes you want me to do that now I go I
don't understand the question and he
goes I'm gonna do that right now and I'm
like okay well if I wanted you to do it
like tomorrow I probably would have
waited and asked you tomorrow but in the
time we've been [ __ ] talking about
this minimally a nail would have been in
the wall
do you know Casey's editing this like oh
my God yes so brutal like I'm like what
do you do how do you operate in life
like this yeah you're never going to get
anything so he's very he's also was born
in Hollywood I was born in New Jersey so
he's like very laid back my husband's
never done a drug in his life and I keep
telling him please do not walk past
anyone who's smoking pot because if you
get a contact now you're gonna be a
vegetable yeah I'm 100 certain of this I
grew up very differently I had a I have
a whole drug history in my past that I
now have nothing going on yeah I've just
really cleaned myself up
um but my husband is like you'd think he
was a [ __ ] like a massive like he has
a problem like you're like dude
I need you to be sober here okay and he
is he is that's all lead back so The
Tick Tock thing he was like I think this
is [ __ ] great you never stop talking
and you finally found an outlet for that
nice and I was like great so he'd come
in and I'd do like a tick tock live and
I'd be on there for like two hours or
like I do twitch for like three hours
and he comes in at the end and he's like
I don't understand like how you can talk
for this stuff yeah and he's like
doesn't even throw her I'm like no I'm
good man I could have gone for another
hour she's getting late and I gotta go
to bed yeah so so he supports you he
supports me he's watching the babies he
supports me sometimes I make him laugh
you know from time to time I think it
gets old after what you know what I mean
like I'm like do you still think I'm
fine but I make him laugh all the time
I'm trying to convince him to get a
vasectomy doesn't think that's funny
oh my God yes first of all I love my
kids but my husband
okay can we just talk about anything
here right yeah
so we talk about buttholes we talk about
anything oh great let me tell you yeah
okay so no filter no so first thing is
my husband was like I want three kids
and he and he and I'm like cool I didn't
I didn't want any so I'll we'll do it
too okay you know what I mean
she's like me yeah I'm like I don't want
anything I want to get married
no I didn't want I mean yeah he's he's
all right okay
like we are like best friends yeah
um but I was like oh well I'll agree to
two Okay you have these conversations
early on so you know you're calling
yourself
yeah anyway so as I'm pregnant with Luca
which is [ __ ] so weird yeah yeah I
was like wait it might look as her
surrogate and I'm kidding so surprised
he's like I'm like plot twist no so so I
go he's like you know I I want to have a
third kid and I go okay so your timing
on this is awful because like hormones I
said this is yeah that's what I'm
talking about like writing on my vagina
in like six months yeah I haven't slept
through the night since I found out I
was pregnant and I'm not peeing every
seven years yeah and then just preach
I'm still living you're peeing and just
a little trickle comes out and you're
like I just hmm I still gotta go you
know what I mean and it's just like this
dumb trickle yeah anyway that's a whole
other thing so he goes he goes I want to
have through and I was like okay that
I'm not that's not happening now of
course we should talk about it after no
no it's still not gonna happen so then
he brings us up again I'm like first of
all stop treating this baby like a
middle child when he hasn't even arrived
yet I don't know what you're doing this
right now we have this conversation
years ago we had an agreement yeah so
this is me fulfilling my agreement yeah
I'm not doing that dude this is not
something you can't change the agreement
also I just turned 39. what the [ __ ] are
you talking about that's a lot you know
what I mean like my window's gonna close
I don't wanna ha whatever anyway he's
trying to he's trying to slide one in
before the door yeah exactly and so I so
then I said and then I go so I'm talking
to my friend of mine and she goes listen
she's like
um my husband had affected me I was like
what what do you mean so she's like yeah
he was like totally against it and then
he got he went to the consultation he
got more information and he did it and
it's like he he loves talking to guys
about it because it was like the best
things that he's ever done because it's
like sex with no consequence now yes
this is my husband's best life you know
what I mean like yeah this is his dream
so I'm like babe can you just he's like
no I'm like first of all don't shut me
down hear me out yeah I have a pitch
listen to the pitch then you can decide
yeah yeah so I tell him I'm like first
of all my first question to my friend
was like I have a really stupid question
and I didn't know this I'm sure you guys
still but I didn't know yes what because
he still come can you still come like
this stuff come out yeah so I was like
dude like did you just have the
sensation you're like like whatever but
there's just nothing because you're
shooting blanks like is it like there's
dust yeah
there's nothing but it does and they're
like no no stuff comes out there's just
no sperm in there is it clear
I don't know if the sperm make up the
cloudiness I'm not sure about the ratio
of what how that works but I do know
that liquid comes out yeah
know what it looks like that's the
problem
a lot of people
actually I'm curious like a lot of
people assume it's like I'll just never
be able to come again it's like no dude
like that's their number one concern
that they'll never come against like no
you're still gonna come so I tell him
that he was good to know I didn't know
that yeah like a ego thing because it's
like I I don't want to be shooting
blanks yeah I want to be a fertile man
that's right that's right I've never
heard a man say did you hear about Phil
shoots blanks now yeah
so when the TV shows I remember seeing
yeah the girl that I the girl whose
husband did it told me she's like there
is like a week of like where they feel
like they kind of lost their manhood
because there is this this like
procreation entity which I get fine
right but she's like then after that
because that's like the for one week you
can't have sex I guess right and then
there's like a day where you have like
no there's one week where you have to
have sex as much as you possibly can
like yeah
I'm like this is
over 10 years like back in my 20s I
can't do that anymore it's not like
after 10 years you're not supposed to be
on yeah so I'm like oh I know that yeah
so I'm like dude this is like an easy
solution and by the way for you because
you're the one that hates wearing
condoms so I'm giving you a solution
it's 15 minute procedure it's fifteen
hundred dollars we can do it twice yeah
yeah then he goes
because we're just rolling thousand
dollars I could whip out for you to whip
it out you know what I mean yeah so he
goes he goes I mean I don't know I go
tell me the reason why what's the what's
the the thing that's holding what is
your consideration about this he goes
you know I just I want to know that I'm
definitely done having kids I go oh easy
conversation let me fully disabuse you
about that okay yeah if you want to have
a third kid full and this is 100 honesty
you go out and you find a woman to
impregnate it's totally fine with me I
will invite that bastard baby into our
home
for holidays I will treat them like
they're my own but it's not coming from
this body I [ __ ] guarantee you would
you be willing to have like go in on a
surrogate no and here's why I'm gonna
tell you so let me tell you the other
part of it so I said then he goes what
if we adopt a baby I go Kayla okay no
here's why I was like
first of all like right now so with my
daughter my husband was up with me a lot
helping out and stuff like that but
right now he's working and he's got
stuff going on he hasn't gotten up at
all
um so there were nights like I slept for
20 minutes and that was it and I you
forget like I have a six-year-old I'm
sure you forgot because your your son is
a lot older right yeah he's 14. yeah so
like you forget like these they teeth
yes there's that they don't sleep for
the first you know and it's like and
it's amazing and it's temporary and
they're wonderful but it's like think
about first of all I said okay where
where does the baby sleep let's I said
let's play out the scenario of having a
third kid so if I have a third kid I
have to get pregnant like right now
because I'm 39 yeah so now Lucas is
we'll just call them Luca 2.0 no he's
fine Luca it's okay so um Luca also so
also is a year and a half and there's an
infant now I have two under two yeah
awesome and here's the thing dude if I
was like a stay-at-home mom and that was
our yeah
you know but I'm not I work 11 hours a
day I'm out of my house yeah so already
I feel like I'm neglecting my daughter
to some degree because there's an infant
yeah so at what point I'm like I
couldn't be a good mom to all three of
those kids and feel good about myself at
the end of my day like I don't want to
do that you know what I mean even if it
was it's not just the idea of yeah how
it wrecks my body and it takes me a full
year to bounce back and lose 50 pounds
to lose right I have to lose a [ __ ]
first grader yeah you know what I mean
I don't know how well that first grader
is eating because my daughter's heavier
but it doesn't matter that's not my
point my point is like I have a whole
being to lose like and you're asking me
to do this again now so I would be like
a house people would be like I don't
know who's pregnant or not or if she's
yeah can I should we ask no yeah no
don't you never ask it's not clear I I
came back from my return leaving a
patient I was talking to patient and she
goes like Oh my god when are you having
your baby and I said he's out I'm dead
inside
[Music]
the funniest story ever that my mom told
me so my mom she's uh clearly not
pregnant but she ended up in her 50s
right yeah she's like 51. okay so she
was telling me the story about how she
she met this lady with so she was with
my grandma and they went to some store
or something and this lady goes up to
her and she goes oh my God can I kiss
your stomach what what so then my
assistant or not this isn't
inappropriate yeah
that's like something maybe you're close
friend people get offended if you touch
their belly yeah no yeah so then she
ends up my mom's like what like okay
[Music]
so then my my grandma is cracking up
she's laughing so [ __ ] hard and then
my mom was like she's laughing too and
then after the lady's like oh a little
she's like saying a prayer and [ __ ] like
yeah just like all in Spanish just being
like Oh cute little babies and then my
mom goes so do you see how like flat my
stomach is so in Spanish she said like
uh Panza or something like that so she
goes
um
anyway the point is that she was like
you see how soft my stomach is it's
nothing but [ __ ] if it was hard to be a
baby so it was better in Spanish but she
ends up like embarrassing I actually
kind of like an English personally yeah
right yeah it's pretty great so then the
lady was like oh my God I'm sorry and
then she walked away wait did she let
her kiss her stomach in that your mom is
your mom that's hilarious dude your mom
is oh my God correct me oh my God
yeah kiss my [ __ ] stomach
she's like you just bust my Burger
King's [ __ ] yeah how does it feel to
kiss [ __ ] waste
I can't yeah
foreign
[Music]
or even if you're assuming don't act
upon it yeah exactly until you hear
something I hope that lady learned her
lesson like you don't want it that's
absolutely humiliating on a level that I
can't even comprehend you know what was
great about the woman who asked me when
I was gonna be like when I was due was
that she just got done telling me
how she's been really like working on
and having these great like successes
and like being a better listener oh my
God no no wait let me take this journey
with me so she says this
and I go yeah and when I was on my
maternity leave oh my God I finished my
sentence and then after I got done
talking she goes
oh wonder when are you having the baby
yeah I'm so [ __ ] big I did my
maternity leave already oh my god when
the baby comes I'm just gonna [ __ ]
have it at the desk whatever you know
what I mean like pre-maternity leave so
I was like this is horrid you're not a
good you're not listening you're not
listening to me you're not improving
also here's your [ __ ] treatment plan
it's a billion dollars
like I have an extra two thousand
dollars that's so funny oh my God I know
people are so rude I remember you were
telling me when we were both pregnant
how people were like asking you are you
having twins no no no no no no are you
having twins are you having twins no are
you sure yeah that part yeah because
they have technology now and there's one
heartbeat and she just has a lot of room
you know what I mean
my daughter when that happened and then
this and and here's the crazy thing most
people that would say [ __ ] like this
were women who have kids
what yeah they're probably these women
that gained just 20 pounds to get
pregnant and then they like they're
they're but I mean you're clearly one of
those women but that's okay I still love
you yeah no I just I was gonna say it
like um
yeah I gained 40 pounds or a little less
than 40. but yeah so you had like 30
something to lose yeah no but even still
like 65 pounds I would never I don't
know what an average is it's supposed to
be 25 to 40. okay she's within that
right now you're a little extra pasta
yeah healthy
oh my God so then so then this one woman
came from downstairs she worked
downstairs in another office and she
comes up and there's like how our office
is you walk into the front desk and then
there's a separate office which is where
our doctor his office is and I was in
there because I was going over stuff
with him and she comes in and I heard
the door and no one was out front so I
like peeked my head out and I was like
Hey and she was like oh did you get so
big they put you in there because
there's no room for you at the front
desk can you believe she said that so at
this point I'm done
so this is my reaction I go
really
really dude that's what you're going to
say to me because I had it I was like
done with like making a joke and she
goes oh no no she's like don't don't do
that she's like don't don't I said no no
no no no no you did that yeah
you take responsibility for that you
just said that you know what I mean if I
didn't mean anything about okay actually
just get [ __ ] I don't know why you're
here you can't borrow anything I don't
know what you need yeah go away but we
don't have it we're closed for the rest
of the day
oh my God yeah
so just a record for anyone watching I
had my baby no there's no life in here
no I'm not currently pregnant
so insane so yeah yeah people are wild
zero uh awareness pregnant women get
treated the worst sometimes like you
know what we either treated the Best
Manners wise but it's almost like
because people feel bad for you like
they'll hold the door for you they'll
let you sit somewhere yeah yeah but at
this time I was like I'm gonna you know
what good thank you can you talk to me a
little bit more about like not wanting
to have kids and then deciding to go
ahead and have yeah
right now we're super anti-means we're
like so uh she's not but there's never
gonna be a life in me yeah never ever
ever
how did you get okay with it I can't
tell nowadays you know what I mean yeah
because literally right before you
arrived I was telling them I'm like I'm
so down to be your surrogate like I'll
do it because I told her I'll tell Clark
that yeah
you have three lined up right now yes
yeah so so when I met my husband like I
have to kind of tell you that story yeah
it is when you met
um
2000 and
oh my God how old was I when we met I
was
25. okay so you've been together for a
while yeah so 15 years now yeah 14 years
yeah yeah holy [ __ ] um okay so anyway
um when we met this was not a love at
first sight Head Over Heels thing so we
were set up to go to lunch together by
friends or by friend actually somebody I
worked for at the time okay they were
like oh you should ask Janina and I was
out that day and and he called me and I
was like okay yeah I'll go to lunch at
this guy fine
so we met for lunch and
I abruptly ended the date because I have
this thing where I dread which I don't
have to worry about this now anymore but
like I would get such anxiety about
having like the first kiss
the first kiss is always gonna suck yeah
because you're gonna kiss differently
and then you get the hang of it yeah but
depending on how quick you are at that
it could be a [ __ ] nightmare so we
had lunch it was great it was like a
midday thing obviously we went for a
walk in the town where because it was a
gorgeous little town and he and I was
like all right I gotta I gotta go like I
just he was like oh oh okay and I was
like yeah call me we should totally do
this again like I got my car and I
laughed so I found out later that he
said to his friends
you know it was okay I mean she was she
was boring but I'd hit it oh
a lot of [ __ ] things not boring not
[ __ ] boring okay so I basically just
married him to I'm still to this day
yeah so
um wait how did you hear this because
somebody's talking friends told me later
because I'm so easy to talk to I'm not
[ __ ] boring
so anyway
um I very early on proved my point so
so he he was like no you were weird like
you were first impression you know you
get like whatever on the first day and I
was like okay whatever dude so we went
out again and when we went out again
he had stood me up he was like oh we
were gonna go to the movies and he goes
I have to go visit my grandfather up
north and I was like I said oh this is
already off to a great place
then I started becoming my sarcastic
self which I really wasn't the first
date and he was like laughing a lot we
were talking a lot
so we got together three months after we
started dating
our both of our leases were going to be
up and we were thinking about moving in
with another couple of you know like a
like in a house yeah yeah
and I was like this is kind of crazy I
would never do this if a friend told me
they were gonna be like slow down yeah
but for some reason it just felt like
the right thing to do we weren't even
saying I love you to each other yet oh
which is so weird but we're like dude
this is gonna like this'll be like 500
each
yeah so
so we move in together and I remember I
and I my thing was like I was like I
don't really want to get married I'm
very like career driven I didn't I
didn't really have I hadn't really had
the you know Epiphany that I wanted to
do comedy at but like I I was like I
love like working I could never just be
a stay-at-home I'm too productive of a
person I'll lose my mind you know what I
mean like so
um
and he wasn't like neither one of us
were like his head over heels infatuated
so it was cool it was like we were like
both chill enough with each other that
it was fine
so as the relationship progressed and
you know we kept dating I remember like
in the beginning I was the first one to
say I love you and we were laying in bed
and it was right before we were talking
about to go to sleep like five months in
or something okay and I was like I love
you and he was like
thank you oh God [ __ ] Star Wars dude
I said what the [ __ ] did you say no my
sister and I go what the [ __ ] did you
just say to me and he goes wait I know
it's way worse he goes I said Thank you
and I go oh I [ __ ] heard you dude I
was giving you a chance to dial it back
like what do you mean and he goes well I
mean like I think that's great like he's
like I don't like I'm not there yet I
could see myself getting there but would
you rather like I lie and say I love you
too I said [ __ ] yes I would yeah what
yeah you lie pause and think of
something else besides thank you I don't
know thank you this is a [ __ ]
business transaction what do you mean
whatever so we're not off to a good
start okay guys this is boring
no no no yeah so I'm like oh anyway so I
don't know I I would have appreciated
that other than a lie yeah I mean I'm
flying is not good but also just thank
you like I don't know
you know what you should have said was
if you wanted to be honest but I would
have appreciated the lie but it's fine
but if you want to go the other rack
okay let me assume that Viewpoint okay
he could have gone
that's so sweet you know what I can
totally see myself getting there too
that's that is better than things no
just thank you the one thing I heard
online was
um that's really sweet
um I think we're
on the same book just different chapters
yeah we'll get there I'll count yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm
getting there yeah I'm getting there you
know
[ __ ] [ __ ] so anyway
this is this is a great conversation
because I'm like what am I doing right
now I'm like I think he deserves a kick
in the balls
so can you sit with me I'll convince you
all your man ain't [ __ ]
by the way we're doing this so that I
could tell you about how I change it
convince me that it's going to be okay
at the end I'm gonna look at you and be
like I don't know what I'm doing
so she's convincing you to sterilize
your husband yeah also I was like why
are they not why instead of circumcising
babies how about we Ed vasectomies and
then they can reverse it when they get
old enough to decide if they want to
have a baby I'm just saying this is an
idea people can think about it yeah it's
less painful yeah you know whatever
instead of anyway circumcision yeah it's
a pretty it's a pretty this kid's a
little kid it gets a little too close to
sterilization
it's probably I'm probably trying to
bring back some really yes
nobody Cuts anything on babies
that there you go I would like to also
if anyone's just tuning in mid can they
just no no
well if you fast forward it
yeah you're related to my husband yeah
um so Jesus Christ so okay where am I
okay so I'm gonna thank you so I thank
you great so fast forward to eventually
he says I love you great wonderful and
did you say thank you yeah yeah I did
okay I 100 did actually what I'm [ __ ]
proud of me yeah he's like he's like you
know what he goes I love you and I went
really anyway yeah I go thank you there
you go it was a very sweet moment and I
really had you said I love you after the
thank you before his I love you you did
have to pause on that no I I waited and
I said and I went really like I was
about to say it and then I switched it
up and I was like thank you yeah so you
know we started talking about the future
and he's like you know I definitely want
to get married and have kids and stuff
and I was like oh it's great you know
thank you uh and so for sharing that
so he so I was like I go you know I I
haven't really ever seen myself get
married but I'm also like not I'm
willing to change my mind about stuff
I'm not very like fix fixated person
like it has to be this way and because I
just feel like there's an irrationality
about that so like I'm willing to be
like okay you know if I met the right
person that fell in love with me and
didn't think I was boring yeah
maybe I would change my mind so um
we were together for about almost two
years and at that point I was like all
right I could see myself like he's we
don't like he's so laid back like he
compliments me really well because I'm
out of 10. like you know what I'm saying
I'm very dramatic I'm very animated like
I've hit this [ __ ] thing God knows
how many times so I don't even believe
in this [ __ ] but Virgo okay yeah I mean
I don't either but I'm pretty spot on
it's unfortunate you know like I'm like
I'm not an astrology person every time I
read it I'm like God damn it again I get
mad because mine's like kind of works
too but I'm like [ __ ] this [ __ ] but I'm
like this this is such [ __ ] yes
exactly yeah so
um I'm like now now I'm starting to go
like okay like I could see I don't know
about kids I really don't think I want
to do that right and I had already had
some [ __ ] up stuff in that area and I
grew I had a weird childhood like I mean
I had a great family my mom was amazing
but my mom and my dad got divorced when
I was young she remarried they had a kid
I like resented that like I was like I
don't know about this and he wants a few
kids like he wants three I don't know
you know and then we started talking
about getting married which I was which
I was like okay
and now I wanted to do that now I got
into that whole like I was like okay
that would be great like that'd be super
cute and fun I could like create this
wedding it would be beautiful I'm
praying to God that when he says when he
said I do you're like thank you yeah
yeah
so so
um he wasn't really like one to go over
and about like you know what I mean like
obviously right from these stories you
could say like thank you like great guy
yeah super chill I don't know a single
person that is an enemy of my husband's
he's so easy to get along with it's not
even funny which was one of the things
that made me like love him so much
because I'm like everyone I talk to like
loves this guy you know what I mean or
they'd be like why didn't we think of
hooking up with Clark you guys are
perfect
so um and he puts up with my [ __ ] and I
know I'm not easy to handle you know
what I mean like I'm not the easiest
person to be around all the time and if
you could find someone that could put up
with your [ __ ] and not make you [ __ ]
feel like a piece of [ __ ] for it oh is
he here
[ __ ] we have a surprise guest today
someone just rang the doorbell
okay so then I started changing my mind
about getting married right and I'm like
okay fine but I'm still not sold in the
kids thing yeah and so I kind of was
like okay he wants to do this three kit
thing I'm okay with one is what I first
said but then I was also like dude
listen if you want you want to do all
this
I could I'll think about it but honestly
like we need to we're not even engage
like what are we doing yeah so what the
[ __ ] and then he had this weird thing of
like well if we get engaged we have to
be engaged for two years I was like two
years I don't know what the [ __ ] you're
talking about right now but you're like
the weirdest person I've ever met with
three kids
wait why
in one year because it was my thing yeah
I was like let's just be good while
you're married
yeah yeah I I don't know I mean like
yeah someone told was it one weird one
this weird chat he had with somebody
that was like some other influenced
things I was like what do you what is
the consideration on two what like okay
so then um he he doesn't really go like
all out and do like crazy romantic
things like he's very sweet but he
doesn't do like
things that are like expensive and
lavish and stuff so he goes I'm going to
surprise you and take you on a trip so
I'm thinking he knows I've always wanted
to go to Hawaii and that's the only
place he could take me that it would be
okay not to ask me to marry him like if
that would give me like I'm okay with
that yeah if he takes me to like
anywhere else I don't give a [ __ ] where
it is it could be Italy he better be
proposing yeah I mean but I really
wanted to go to Hawaii for what I don't
know why just to go yeah yeah I'm 25
yeah I'm gonna go lay on the goddamn
Beach right so
he him and his his cousin and his wife
at the time uh take me to the airport
and I haven't seen my boarding pass and
they're like just packed for the summer
it's the summer I'm like okay and I
didn't know where I was going and we'd
go to the airport it was really fun and
the security guy takes my boarding pass
he goes she doesn't know where she's
going and he's like up have fun in
Georgia and I'm like thanks for playing
it's gonna be [ __ ] joking
obviously we're going to Georgia this is
going to be I'm trying to just work out
like okay like how do I move out like
I'm trying to yeah
this is gonna be rough so four months
left on the lease exactly like I'm
literally doing like my finances it's so
funny as we're going through the airport
and they couldn't have planned this they
they could they didn't plan this but it
was perfect because as we're going
through LAX every single gate I'm
looking at the city right so I'm like
okay we're not going to Cincinnati we're
not going to New York we're not going to
Honolulu I was like that sucks okay
we're not going here we're not going
there and I and it's the last time
and this is how dumb I am and it's a
last terminal and the destination says
Kona and I go where the [ __ ] is that
you wanted to go to Hawaii
I could be in Thailand I have no idea
right so my the girl though the wife of
my of my cousin-in-law holds up this
book which she I guess ordered on I
don't know why she just had this [ __ ]
book right and it says Kona the big
island and I was like oh and I of course
dramatically I fall to the floor I'm so
excited I'm literally I'm laying on the
ground it's disgusting actually now that
I think about it there's an airport
um so excited and I'm like this is gonna
be wonderful and they have a time share
there and it's this beautiful trap right
and then we get there and we park the
car and we're gonna walk down this like
weird path to the beach and I was like
guys I've seen this [ __ ] in horror
movies like we're gonna die actually I'm
gonna be the only Survivor because I
know what's going on as I'm saying this
week there's like some weird [ __ ]
dude playing a banjo I'm like we're so
dead
times right wait a banjo not a ukulele I
don't know maybe yeah
[Applause]
I'm Big Island it could have been
it could have been two lava rocks I
don't [ __ ] know okay all I know is
he's a he's [ __ ] sketchy dude and
he's like 110. yeah and he's playing an
instrument
I don't know it's all romantic it's like
some [ __ ] banjo I don't know so but
no he was like a home I don't know what
he's doing anyway it doesn't matter so
as we like curve around there's this
like
rock out in the middle of the water it
looks like a screensaver yeah and
there's waves crashing on the Rock like
the little [ __ ] mermaid like a
mermaid land and she's just standing
like and it's just weird you know and
I'm like oh my God this is gorgeous
right so we go we walk out on the Rock
and his cousin's gonna take a photo of
somewhere and we're like this and it's
slippery because there's like algae or
whatever yeah and if we fall we're
probably gonna die you know what I mean
so it's fine so we're staying there and
we're arm and arm and I'm smiling take
the picture and he starts slipping on
the Rock oh and but but this is how
selfish I am like the whole time I'm
like what are you doing what are you
doing keeping my smile what are you
doing what are you doing and and then I
look and he's on it he's on one knee oh
and all I can say like a [ __ ] lunatic
is what are you doing what are you doing
what are you doing and I can't stop it
right so
I don't remember what he said it was
beautiful I have no to this day I have
no idea and
I didn't realize at the time but he told
me when he opened up the box it was
upside down so he quickly flipped it if
it had bounced out yeah
I would have been like banjo guy come
kill us [ __ ] are you kidding me
so I was I was like okay so I'm crying
and then I decided to the girl I'm like
because this is why you told me to look
nice today and I didn't um like no
makeup because I'm just like one with
the beach or whatever
so and the whole time they were videoing
this not taking a picture so you have
this video I have a video oh my gosh
nice so so he can't marry him and then I
was like this is I'm like oh my God my
whole Viewpoint of liked it I was like
yeah I'll [ __ ] make your babies yeah
awesome and then we want to be engaged
for two years I was like this is
[ __ ] but okay because I guess we're
planning it so if I do half a task a
week I'll be able to take my [ __ ]
time and not get stressed out anyway
engage for two years engaged I don't
know I registered married for two years
before trying to get no no that's super
weird
for on our first date in 2009 and we got
married in 2013. four years later
because we got engaged at two years and
we got married at four right okay and
then so now when he asked me for this
third kid I'm like [ __ ] you we should
have gotten started earlier yeah
what do you mean do you understand that
when I was pregnant what it was called
it was called a geriatric intervention
yeah yeah isn't that offensive it's
super offensive AMA it's like first it's
Eternal age no as soon as I had my baby
they [ __ ] changed it oh damn I was
like thank you cancel culture for
stepping in on after my babies out of me
now after I've been called geriatrics
are you [ __ ] kidding me dude so rude
after my doctor's like well this is
considered a geriatric pregnancy
I'm like with what that my vagina
doesn't get a gray hair while I'm
pushing it like what do you mean I can't
see it so who cares
and he was it was like okay at the end
of the day what really changed my mind
was you know when I was dating and stuff
it was like
what are you trying to do in your day
you're trying to find the [ __ ]
companion you're gonna have whether you
marry them or not you're trying to find
someone that you enjoy their company
enough to be around that you don't no
one likes to go to bed at night by
themselves and wait like at the end of
your life right you're trying to find
someone to like really be with and after
at a certain point of dating you kind of
get like over it you know you're like
I'm [ __ ] tired of this [ __ ] and like
and nowadays I don't know how the [ __ ]
people do it because everything's online
yeah you know and it's and I have a
Barrett you know my co-worker he's with
the thing and swiping and I'm like oh my
God this is unbelievable and he tells me
about these dates and I'm like dude I
don't [ __ ] envy you like you you want
to find someone that you're like this is
my [ __ ] person dude yeah and for
Clark and I really it's more like we're
not like oh look at them they're so
madly in love we're like look at those
two they're [ __ ] hilarious like we're
best friends yeah you know and that's
and that to me was like that's worth
somebody I want to spend the rest of my
life with it's somebody that that's my
best friend you know what I mean he
knows all my crazy [ __ ] he's seen me
at my [ __ ] worst he taught me like
like when I had the baby and the baby
was not over nine pounds and 23 inches
long that's almost two feet long guys
he's like babe it was like your vagina
was Mary Poppins back
I didn't know when the baby was gonna
fire now I don't get the [ __ ] out of
here like I don't want do you mean like
this miracle plowed its way through me
and now we're like yeah exactly yeah she
actually both of her babies were home
births we were talking about that
because you know how I was I wanted to
do a birth center birth which I was like
no [ __ ] way before I had kids am I
having a baby at home yeah yeah so
that's me absolutely not I was like
people are people who do that are crazy
yeah how did you change your mind I
watched a documentary on Netflix called
The Business of Being Born
that's literally the reason why I didn't
want to go to the hospital a friend of
mine a friend of mine had a home birth
and I was like all right tell me about
it I think you're a psycho [ __ ]
lunatic person and you're like your
babies are alive but tell me about it so
she did and I was like okay and yeah
home births are more dangerous but
they're actually way like significantly
safer than hospital rooms well here's
what did it for me like my midwives had
been doing this for 50 years and had
actually delivered more babies vaginally
than my OB GYN had because OB gyns that
do more C-sections because they're
surgeons yeah right so I was like that's
interesting and then our transfer like
right to the hospital like if God forbid
something happens was less than five
percent okay so I was like okay and then
I took this the game changer for me was
I took a 10-week classic every Sunday we
went for an hour or whatever and it was
like a birthing class
um this woman named Kathy Killebrew she
was a [ __ ] phenomenal class and now
she does them online that gave you so
much information about what's going on
because you're terrified but you're then
you also have to remind yourself at some
point they're not this is not something
like you know what we're gonna [ __ ]
you're a guinea pig we're gonna see how
this goes if you could do this this is
how we'll make humans like this has been
going on for a long time
this is not you know what I mean like
this is not some [ __ ] test yeah you
know so that chilled me out and then
like finding out all the things about it
but I was but also I was like you know
what it's okay I'll try it at home and
then the second if I ever did have a
third baby which I won't because you're
listening yeah where the [ __ ] is shut
down yeah okay also I'm incredibly
[ __ ] fertile like I look at his penis
and I'm pregnant like it's I'm it's
insane like I might need to borrow some
eggs wait you can have them I will give
you a full [ __ ] dozen so
it is insane like so I'm like I will
wrap your body in Saran Wrap before you
can look me lovingly in the eyes ever
again like I'm not I'm not doing this
and it's and it's a lot so it's like I I
feel like the second time that and when
I had my birth was so different than the
first one that I was like if this
happened a third time I would consider
going to the hospital and like planning
and doing a season yeah was it to have
that experience or you've just had the
good experiences and you're like well we
could just go ahead and it was I want to
be traumatized it was yeah no no I I
probably I say that and I probably
wouldn't it was that with my daughter it
was like this beautiful kind of like I
woke up in the morning and I had like
very light period cramps that weren't
even that painful and I was like oh I
think something's happening today might
be the day you know like like you see
some [ __ ] on tv you know what I mean
and then as the day went on it got a
little bit more intense but it was
happening like slowly and my body could
handle it you know what I mean like it
was on a very low like gradient you
didn't have any
um shot then right now
so at home for about there was about an
hour time period that I was like this
like that they call it transition which
is like the where every woman goes give
me the drugs and I can't take it but if
they just hold out a little longer
you're about anybody where you can push
and when you push it feels amazing yeah
because you could do something about it
okay and you want to push your body
wants to push your body is
nine months pregnant and the baby comes
out yeah their uterus pushes the baby
out it's literally it takes a while
because the woman's not up and helping
it but it it that's it's like literally
it's gonna come out the baby's coming
out so yeah so with her it was like okay
it was intense for an hour and I was
like if I'm not I'm sorry I'm horrified
no no it's not it's just my mouth is
watering I
might cut this sorry it's okay so so
um I was like okay this is this is
intense like if this is not transition I
don't think I can do this I'm at my
threshold for pain I told my husband he
goes what do you need me to do I'm like
I need you to call everyone we know that
has three kids or that has two kids
because this is my first and tell them
they're a [ __ ] idiot we're doing it
again start with my mother and then call
this [ __ ] [ __ ] because my best
friend lived right next door at the time
and I was outside walking and I pointed
to that house and then the midwives
coming like we need to go for a walk I
go what do you what I'm exhausted like I
said I said do you guys even have kids
that go yeah cause that's the [ __ ]
point all right I don't think you know
what you're doing I need to sit down if
you keep your body moving it's better
for them yeah so then next thing you
know I could push and then they're like
so we need you to push like you're
pooping I was like okay if I can do that
all the time so um so I did and then I
was like that's good right and they're
like nope like harder I'm like what okay
so then I do that for the next one you
have to wait for the contraction so
you're just kind of like laying there in
between it's not like TV where like you
push push pushing the babies out it's
like you push you wait for the next
contraction to come you push through the
trash with the contraction yeah okay
well did you ever feel your body they
push for you like that uncontrolled yes
and then you you can push with it but
like if not you're just waiting for the
next one but you're not in any pain
while you're waiting because there's so
much pressure and you're so glad you
could finally like do something about it
that it's anyway it doesn't matter
so the next one I'm like okay here we go
I'm gonna do it I'm gonna harder than
I'm pooping right like harder than poop
okay got it do it still not enough I'm
like I'm sorry I we gotta go we gotta go
then because I can't do this yeah so
then I go like I actually can't do this
so she takes my hand and shoves it
between my legs and I feel Olivia's head
and my eyes fill up with tears because
I'm like oh she's right there like I
didn't know yeah and I was like okay
like it brought me up to like a point
where I was like okay I could do that
you know what I mean yeah okay we're
almost there at the finish line so then
I do it I push the next time
and they go that was perfect like if you
do that again and I go oh no that was
all I had in me there was no again this
is how she lives now
so so I go what do you what do you mean
I go first of all I just guys okay while
we wait for the next contraction I have
a little tip for first-time moms when
you're at their house and this is
happening and they're like yeah I go
um and I'm whispering because we're
trying to keep the you know very calm
you know environment
good energy I go to a little tip now
keep in mind the whole time Clark's
laying next to me and he's just like
being supportive and like and there's
like snacks out for the midwives and he
comes and he's like chewing what the
[ __ ] are you eating
oh my God
do you need anything I just want to make
sure you're [ __ ] comfortable babe
this [ __ ] guy right here what
in between contract you're eating cash
what in your ear that's driving me crazy
[ __ ] protein
pushing out his kids so and he's so he
doesn't really see what's going on
because he's here laying down right
what the [ __ ] are you doing so anyway
so anyway so I go just a little tip for
first-time moms like when you have a
first time out this is what I need you
to do don't tell them to push like
they're pooping yeah okay because I
don't know how you guys [ __ ] yeah but
what communicates better to a first-time
mom is like so now you're gonna push
like your whole body's gonna go inside
out okay
I can't do that a second time yeah I was
also used to be a smoker like I'm like I
don't have that lung capacity
so
whatever next contraction she was out
also they're like you need to Bear down
you know how they always like they bear
down like yeah your chinchers but I
wasn't doing that I was like and so my
eyes were swollen shut up after like I
had put so much pressure in my face did
you get those little like Cherry things
uh no I didn't but I just looked yeah I
have a picture it is so [ __ ] up how
how I oh God I just look like a swollen
hot mess like I'll go to Michelin man
so then they went they then they weigh
her and she's nine [ __ ] pounds I'm
like yeah [ __ ] felt like it yeah and
um is Clark a ginormous tall man he's
five eleven but his he has a couple of
six foot tall men's family I think is
why and I'm five five I'm not you know
I'm not like abnormally taller shorts is
pretty normal so they
um they they take her and they wear and
they do all this stuff and they put her
on my chest and you know so midwives
don't believe in well my midwives and
don't believe in cutting you like giving
an episiotomy they don't believe in that
they're like if we do that and you tear
it's going to be worse because they've
already started the tear which makes
sense yeah if you caught a piece of
paper and you stretch the paper it's
gonna it's gonna change if you go like
this and trusted paper it might tear but
it might not you know what I mean so I
they didn't do that to me and I tore a
little bit on my own and they novocaine
you down there I don't even feel it and
I'm holding my baby the whole time and
she's selling me up and then she gives
me my checkup six weeks later and she
looks down there she's like oh man this
is beautiful work she goes looks better
than what it did before you started I'm
like what the [ __ ] is that supposed
oh geez can you imagine though what
should people say yeah better than
before it was ripped well you just made
me realize it's like a pregnant she goes
it looks better than it did when you
first got I was like oh okay what is
that this is the theme of this episode
the [ __ ] people say this [ __ ] yes so
then um when I have Luca Clark wasn't
laying down next to me he was standing
up here so he got to see he's deleting
cashews
there's no [ __ ] Snapchat you need to
you better [ __ ] do it
I wasn't even what happened with Luca
was was I was like disoriented yeah like
I'm gonna tell you what happened so he
was five days late my daughter was 11
days early so I didn't know what was
going on and I went into labor but it
was false labor where nothing was
happening basically like you're not
dilating you're not the baby's not
dropping so they just left and labor
stopped and fine with Luca with Luca
with so with Luca five days late I get
up to go to the bathroom Clark and Liv
are sitting on the couch watching a
movie I go pee I go to wash my hands I
come back from washing my hands and
there's water running down my leg now I
watered in break with Olivia until I was
about to push so I didn't really know
about it there's water running down and
I'm like I can't still be peeing right
because I mean things haven't gotten
that bad like I'm big and my stomach's
out to here but I'm not no and then I
sit down on the toilet and I wipe and I
let him it's like it's clear I'm like
it's not pee like it just was different
it was like almost like slippery a
little bit like something
so I stand up again and more again I'm
looking at the floor I'm like Clark and
he's like I go I think this is my water
breaking yeah so he he goes I'm gonna
call them I said first of all just calm
the [ __ ] down yes don't come in at a
[ __ ] ten yeah [ __ ] hot with this
kind of energy dude
so so he goes and he's like shut up babe
and he comes to the bathroom and he goes
to wipe it up I said don't wipe up the
the fluid he goes why I go because I
know my [ __ ] Midwife and she's a
lunatic and she's gonna want me to taste
it
just stay with me so
this will be the last time I'm ever on
the show people so
so it's on the floor so and I'm sitting
in the toilet and and uh I go so I think
my water just broke she goes okay is it
on the floor I need you to taste it oh
so I'm like
and I taste it and I said it tastes like
the ocean like salt water what she goes
up because you know why why oh geez the
amount of times they get false reports
that your water broke and it was urine
oh grosses you makes you come and they
come what is pee taste like I mean I
don't know but no but it's not salty and
that's the thing I mean like food is
salty I didn't know that yeah I didn't
either okay now I do okay go to the
ocean anymore
it's just Mother Nature's ambulance
my eyelashes already
I'm actually getting I'm sweating also
yes I'm just really loving it so so
um mind blown I did not know that so
yeah so I just I said she goes well your
water broke you're having this baby
today now it's 5 30 p.m my contractions
haven't started yet but I'm worried
because when your contractions start and
you have all your water they're not so
bad but when you have dry labor meaning
some of the water's gone that cushion's
gone it hurts so I'm scared now I'm
scared I'm waiting for it to come right
wait did you have a good or was it like
trickling out no no it was it was quite
a puddle but it wasn't like I still had
enough fluid in me but it wasn't all of
it it wasn't like a gush okay but it was
like running down like almost like I was
peeing yeah so because mine wouldn't
stop trickling yeah trickling and
trickling and trickling this wasn't
really like a trickle this was more of
like a good stream and then it stopped I
see and I was like okay and then I went
outside in case it kept coming I was
just like let me stand in the backyard
whatever and I'm gonna Sway and do
whatever I'm gonna [ __ ] do waiting
and then at 6 30 an hour later
I got my first contraction and I was
like
Clark this is starting at a 10. yeah
like this is intense and I don't know
what's going on and all I know is that
it's going to get worse from here right
because that's what happened last time
and I can't do that yeah like this isn't
this is violent and I don't know what's
going on and I had a feeling that the
reason why he wasn't dropping was
because he was stuck on his cord so I
went and got an ultrasound and the guy's
like when they're that big you can't you
can't see the court so the chord stuff
happens like in retrospect like they
have to see after the baby I'm like cool
do you think maybe your contraction came
out at 10 because you already started
with fear
no I think it came at a 10 because I was
already dilated three centimeters from
two weeks ago so my body was ready and I
kept saying they kept saying he wasn't
dropping I'm like I think he's stuck on
his cord right so I get the contraction
and the reason why now I can answer that
confidently is because I did have that
thought and I was like all right I'm
like let me keep this as chill as
possible right I'm a very like I'm a
very spiritual person a very positive
person like let me just calm down like
let me not do that right I don't want to
cut I don't want to do that
but
um
6 30 two hours later I was holding him
wow fast with my daughter it was an
all-day thing I took me an hour to push
her out I just pushed him out in 20
minutes and when he came out and Clark
was standing here he said Janine and
they did none of them told me this while
this was happening because of course
they didn't want to create any like
upset or worry
after everything was done my husband
goes babe
when he came out his head came out and
his cord was around his neck and the
Midwife wouldn't take it off but she had
no slack
so at one point she goes to the next
push you're just going to keep pushing
and don't stop another okay something's
wrong but I'm gonna just keep I'm not
going to worry about it yeah so I have a
job to do I'm gonna get it you're fine
yeah so the next one came and I did
I felt him slide out of me he goes when
he came out she was just unraveling him
it was around his neck his arms his
belly so I was right he was like
suspended up there and he couldn't drop
oh damn that's why all this fall sleep
so when I was ready to push even she did
she checked me and she goes yeah you can
start pushing but you're gonna have to
push him down the birth canal because
he's still not dropping and I was like
[ __ ] man so thank God everything was
fine right because I had a home birth
and these guys are pros and they have
oxygen like they knew they didn't even
need to put them on auction but they
have all this stuff it's not like they
come like little mamushkas with these
like scarves
they have some equipment so much [ __ ]
equipment as soon as they get there
they're in the room setting up for like
an hour it's insane so it was it was I'm
so grateful he's okay but yeah Clark saw
what he saw and I was like I don't even
was he like blue for some like was he
losing oxygen know but um you know I
have a photo of my daughter on my chest
right after she was born and she's very
like pink and I have the same photo of
Luca and I looked at them just recently
actually and he was pretty gray in
comparison crazy and thank God he's
totally was told because when you have a
home birth in the state of California
you have I think 24 to 48 hours to bring
your baby to a pediatrician to get
checked out so I did that of course what
I don't know where else anything I think
people don't um you need to because you
need you when you have a home birth you
have to get their social security card
and their birth to get on your own and
they're hearing the hospital doesn't do
it for everything so you need the note
from the pediatrician saying that the
baby was born here because some
sometimes people come from like you know
other countries and they're like I had
my baby here and I need and they're like
yeah we need a doctor's note saying that
that baby was born in the states yeah so
um so I I went and whatever and then
um then he was everything was perfect he
was perfect but I was just like what the
[ __ ] yeah that's cool so that's why and
then and I did hear Clark say on the
phone to a friend like you know I don't
know that I can ask Janine to do this a
third time like after seeing yeah you
know seeing this again like that she had
a really intense go of it like it was it
was pretty like he's like the and the
whole thing was like I was in I started
off a transition basically right yeah
yeah and I had no rest in between like I
didn't have a minute to gather myself
before then it was just one and I was
like this is not how this was the first
time you know what I mean like so and
they say that the second kid you have
comes quicker than the first so I
thought all right well if I count from
those fluttery weird cramps till then I
was holding her that was like a 12-hour
day it was only intense for like an hour
but it was about 12. so okay six hours
that's great so that's like half but I
love that this was three hours like I'm
like what yeah and really two because my
water broke but then nothing happened
for an hour yeah right so I was like
yeah dude I'm I'm uh are you okay Tina
oh this is my nightmare yeah
congratulations
congratulations can we do this I don't
know so we can do everyone's experience
is different
um and I remember people being like you
know oh my God was it I was like
actually it was really beautiful you
know what I mean like all [ __ ] Liars
for for all liars no my my son it wasn't
it wasn't a beautiful experience but my
daughter it was like
and oddly enough like he's so [ __ ]
happy all the time even the pediatrician
was like is he always happy really her
Luca too yeah my Luca is always smiling
and and that's the thing I was like even
because you know you wake up in the
middle of the night and you go in the
room and he and I go in and I look at
him and he smiles up at me like oh good
you heard me like it's like a weird like
these kids like and you know that it's
temporary and you're [ __ ] tired but
you're gets temporary and this like I
made a [ __ ] person dude yeah no
[ __ ] awesome this is like this is so
it it is absolutely worth it and it's
all temporary and whatever but it's like
when you're in it it's it's [ __ ]
called Labor for a reason it's [ __ ]
work dude you know what I mean like kids
you have to work you know it you do and
it and it you get through it and it's
fine and you know and there's people who
don't want to do that and they schedule
C-sections and they're holding their
baby in great you know I mean those
babies are still healthy babies and
wonderful you know what I mean and
um but for me I I I did say that to him
I was like if because if I got pregnant
again what does that mean an hour like I
can't what you just pop that even faster
because somebody was like don't you
think that was easier and I was like
absolutely not no I don't know people
will say that like oh your second one
it's easier because they come out faster
yeah it's more convinced and I'm like no
I prefer it not to be condensed actually
I was okay so just having the day that
this is the day I'm gonna have my kid
yeah it's gonna be our special day we're
gonna meet each other they're growing
this goddamn baby for nine months you
know what I mean I look like a house was
it worth it let's meet I'll [ __ ] if I
can tell you yeah I don't know I'll let
you know oh that's so true well it's so
great to hear from you it's so great to
have you here and share your stories no
no thank you thank you so much no
seriously no and Jay's gonna be here for
another two more episodes we have her
three total so you guys can look forward
to her in the upcoming weeks and once
again check out her Instagram and her
Tick Tock at jokes by Jay and make sure
to check out our sponsors in the
descriptions we love you
see you next week thank you guys
I'm gonna go Vault it
[Music]